raymond brûlant chicano
[Applaudissements]
je sais en le voyant vous adorez obama
vous vous dites il est toujours aussi
beau cool parfait et patati patata
oui vous avez raison en france ce serait
impossible et vous vous dites
obama peut repasser arrêtez tout
l'amérique a des problèmes sur la route
de la reconquête de la maison blanche
cette année de campagne fut bien
difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment
[Musique]
parce que le tout-puissant défendre nos
enfants qu'ils protègent nos élus
officiels ce que nous disons c'est qu'il
faut honorer tous ceux qui parfois
meurent pour conserver cette liberté que
nous chérissons tous que nous soyons
tous considérés comme égaux et que la
vérité écarte le mal pour le bien commun
de tous que le seigneur nous guide dans
ce chemin amen
[Musique]
c'était il y ait un nom ces gens qui
prient ont peur non nous ne sommes pas
dans l'amérique conservatrice qu'on vous
montre à longueur d'écran mais au
premier meeting de barack obama il a
commencé à faire campagne en allant voir
son peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
release in germany
quatre ans après l'équipe d'obama le met
en scène comme une rock star de la
politique
estrade arrivée sur musique patriotique
le président candidat en conquête des
voix
[Applaudissements]
eles got to be back est chaude en banco
c'est effectivement le retour quatre ans
plus tard mais le contexte est différent
dans cette bourgade comme le reste de
l'amérique blessé par la crise est
obsédé par le chômage
un an de l'élection je suis frappé par
ces visages plus personne ne serait
devant obama comme en 2008
on ne veut plus le toucher mais l'écouté
tous attendent de lui autre chose que
des belles phrases le candidat-président
fait de son mieux
[Musique]
à la sortie du meeting c'est le calme
qui surprend personne de l'ovationner
comme en 2008 l'amérique profonde fan
d'obama l'emt elle encore je m'appelle
donna nous sommes soeur à vous êtes
soeur pensez vous que le président sera
réélu
j'y crois je l'espère je l'espère bien
en tout cas il aura mon vote pensez vous
que c'est difficile pour lui en ce
moment je le pensais les républicains
lui font la vie dure ils ne veulent pas
voter ces réformes
en effet avec un congrès républicains
farouchement hostile à obama rien n'est
facile pour lui il ne reste plus au
président que sa parfaite machine de
campagne pour gagner
avec une nouveauté fabriqué pour 2012
grand douanes
[Musique]
grande one c'est ce bus blindé aux
vitres teintées équipées d'un système
sophistiqué de satellites pour lancer
une attaque nucléaire grand douanes a
coûté 1 million de dollars et permet au
président candidat de sillonner
l'amérique profonde
en ce mois de novembre le camp
républicain a déjà une surprise pour le
contrer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
herman cain originaire lui aussi de
chicago et le bon noir de service du
parti républicain il prône 9 % d'impôts
pour tous et en quelques jours
cette proposition le fait devenir un des
hommes les plus populaires du pays
alors je décide d'aller voir ce
républicain en tête de tous les sondages
en novembre
bonjour mr
nous sommes très contents de vous
rencontrer nous sommes ravis d'être la
première télévision française à vous
rencontrer beaucoup de gens en france
sont surpris que vous soyez noir et
républicains quelle est votre réaction
il y a beaucoup de noirs républicain que
vous ne voyez jamais dans les médias
il y en a beaucoup plus qu'on
l'imaginait je le sais bien parce que je
suis un conservateur républicain depuis
des décennies aux états unis ce
phénomène n'est pas inhabituel mais les
médias les plus importants n'en parle
que très rarement
il ne met jamais les politiciens ou les
ricains noir en une la différence entre
obama et moi c'est que je suis plus
beaux et plus intelligents et plus
expérimentés non je suis vraiment plus
beau et puis j'ai plus de sagesse
j'ai plus d'expérience que lui comme
dirigeant d'entreprise et pour résoudre
les problèmes
l'expérience c'est ce qui compte le plus
il a en effet beaucoup d'expérience kane
et pas simplement politiques comme les
médias américains vont très vite le
révéler sa demi vie il s'est jeté sur
moi et allait sa main sur ma jambe sous
ma jupe j'ai été très surprise et très
choqué j'ai dit qu'aux faits de viol
vous savez que j'ai un petit ami m'a dit
mais tu veux un boulot bye bye kane le
harcèlement sexuel aux états unis ça ne
pardonne pas dans une campagne
présidentielle
le lendemain de ma rencontre fulgurante
avec n en me réveillant dans ma chambre
la matinale de chicago m'offre le
séduisant et si important rahm emmanuel
ancien directeur de cabinet de barack
obama
je suis sûr que le président obama sera
réélu parce que les gens savent quel
genre de miley ils connaissent sa force
de caractère
il n'a jamais abandonné son combat pour
le bien de l'amérique et cela
contrastera avec n'importe quel
républicain qui sera en face de lui
parce que ces gens là ne veulent pas
représenter l'ensemble dé american pour
la première fois dans les années 2000
2010 la classe moyenne a vu ses revenus
diminuer ce qui ne s'était jamais
produit dans l'histoire de l'économie
américaine
rahm emmanuel avec son beau sourire fait
bien son job
ce millionnaire est toujours très proche
du pouvoir et orchestre en coulisses la
stratégie de campagne
il est aussi devenu maire de chicago la
ville d'obama l'emploi du temps de rahm
emmanuel ce jour-là précise qu'il va
faire campagne pour le président le
rendez vous est donné dans un des
quartiers les plus démunis de la ville
la maison blanche et toute sa sécurité
se sont invités dans un jardin de la
communauté la plus pauvre
toute la presse de chicago est convié
cette presse locale si importante
invité pour quelques heures dans la
bulle des journalistes accrédités de la
maison blanche
moi je la connais mais je découvre qu'on
ne peut bouger ou filmer sans permission
nous sommes parqués dans des enclos pour
journalistes
mais rassurez vous l'image du jour je
les ai eus avec en prime sa réaction
exclusif
[Musique]
je suis parti dans l'iowa ma région
favorite dans l'amérique des campagnes
même si on décembre il y fait nuit à 14
heures
[Musique]
ici deux millions d'habitants vote en
premier chaque hiver lors des primaires
à sioux city michele bachmann est la
seule femme candidate républicaine de
cette campagne
il y a vraiment une différence entre
tous les candidats et ce genre de forum
est très bien pour évaluer le programme
de chacun d'entre nous comment nous
comptons nous mesurer à obama et comment
nos voix résonneront dans tout le pays
la loi va provoquer un véritable
tremblement de terre politique qui
décidera du sort du prochain président
je vous assure qu'avec moi on va ma sera
le président d'un seul mandat
[Musique]
merci tout le monde que dieu vous
bénisse à 56 ans michele bachmann est
entré en politique comme député du
minnesota c'est aussi l'une des
fondatrices du tea party l'extrême
droite républicaine
elle a cinq enfants et on a adopté 23
autres c'est une nouvelle tendance de la
politique américaine
une femme de plus de 45 ans jolie sexy
télégénique et hyper conservatrice au
hit parade de la poignée de mains en
politique je classe michele bachmann en
tête du palmarès mondial
je reviendrai pour en faire plus
ravi de vous rencontrer michel c'est ma
fille maya je l'aurait deviné elle a
beau cheveux quel est votre nom et le
média vous n'êtes jamais fatigué vous
aiderez faire campagne
oh oui je suis ici chez moi je suis né
dans l'iowa est très heureuse d'être là
maintenant
michele bachmann a peu de toi m'accorder
il lui reste encore quelques mains à
serrer sur le parking
super boulot ailleurs je vous ai vu à la
télé oh merci mais je dois reprendre mon
but ce que dieu vous bénisse
[Musique]
salut les gars je vous vois très vite
malgré cette belle énergie michele
bachmann elle aussi un moment en tête
des sondages ne tient pas la route et
s'effondre dans l'iowa pour obama en
2008 tout avait commencé à des moines la
capitale de l'iowa
quatre ans plus tard là aussi l'ambiance
a changé alors vous êtes déçu par obama
oui je suis contre obama je suis
supporter de romenay pourquoi parce que
c'est le meilleur homme pour battre
obama remet il a de l'expérience en
politique dans les affaires les romney
lui peut aller jusqu'au bout pour battre
obama a donc dégagé de la maison blanche
en iowa on n'a pas peur d'exprimer ses
idées contre obama
tous se cristallisent ici sur un d'état
mais plus sensibles de la campagne le
rôle de la femme et le droit à
l'avortement
tous les opposants d'obama se sont donc
donné rendez vous un sommet anti
avortement
au menu un film produit par mike
huckabee ancien candidat du parti
républicain dans les primaires 2008
le film n'est pas à base d'imagés
spectaculaires mais fait le portrait de
plusieurs familles dont les enfants ont
échappé à l'avortement
vous pouvez montrer ce que vous avez non
votre petit panier oui bien sûr alors
voilà ma boîte et je suis d'abord eux
montrés les plus précis
ouf
ce que j'ai ici cela en sept semaines
oui lui 5 9 10 semaines
[Musique]
alors 7 8 9 et 10
celui-ci à 20 semaines
voilà
on soutient tous les candidats enfin
ceux qui sont contre l'avortement bien
sûr au programme des réjouissances on
peut aussi observer les chanteuses deux
soeurs prônant l'abstinence et le
dévouement à la patrie
[Musique]
en allemagne
mais sinon
non
mais
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
m
que pensez-vous du président obama
nous prions sincèrement pour lui de tout
notre coeur nous prions pour que dieu
guide et aide nos dirigeants il est
clair que c'est un travail au dessus des
forces d'une seule personne
oui c'est le travail le plus dur au
monde et nous prions aussi pour les
filles d'obama pour sa femme
c'est une famille avec nos croyances
nous sommes plutôt enclin à soutenir le
candidat rick s'en sort-on mais nous
apprécions vraiment le rôle d'obama en
tant que fer et marie il a pris de
bonnes décisions pour le bien de notre
pays comme tué oussama ben laden
c'était la bonne chose à faire mais pour
cette élection de 2012
nous soutenons un candidat bien
américains ayant de vraies valeurs
ici les républicains n'ont qu'un nom à
la bouche
rick santorum son signe de
reconnaissance un débardeur en laine il
est la nouvelle idole de l'iowa
[Musique]
qu'avez vous à dire sur cette élection
est sûre cette campagne les gens vous
découvre ici on a eu droit tout le monde
parle de vous est ce un combat dur
naturellement c'est un combat dur tout
le monde doit être président c'est très
compétitif et très dur mais c'est une
chance je représente dans ma famille la
première génération installée en
amérique
mon père est venu du nord de l'italie et
c'est une bénédiction pour moi de
pouvoir essayer d'être président et
d'être considéré sérieusement pour cette
fonction quelle est la chose la plus
difficile tenter de rencontrer le plus
de gens possible rencontrer des gens
sans te rome l'a très bien fait avec sa
famille il a sillonné les routes de
l'iowa et avec six économies il en a
même fait une pub qu'il aura aussi fait
diffuser avant tout les journaux
télévisés dans les temps
[Musique]
tous mes leaders des douanes va
si tu as ribéry et ses symptômes
benbitour
instruit tous
c'est tout
le foot
d'accord
[Musique]
pendant sa campagne rick santorum a le
sens du public et aussi celui de la
formule il y a rien de plus fondamental
pour notre pays que les notions de foi
de famille de liberté et de combat anti
avortement vous voulez envoyer un
message pour que tout le monde comprenne
ce qui vous tient à coeur dans cette
élection
vous savez ce qui vous reste à faire que
dieu vous bénisse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout se joue souvent dans l'iowa
ce swing states comme on dit anita
balance une fois une voix démocrate et
une autre fois républicain et il donne
toujours l'air du temps à la nuit tombée
je suis donc allé dans les petites
villes comme ici a su city ou un soir de
décembre un débat télévisé a lieu
[Musique]
les débats télévisés sur cette campagne
il faut tous les suivre pendant les
primaires les républicains ont fait plus
de 25 des bat un record historique
d'audience et à chaque fois au rendez
vous les chaînes pulvérise ses records
où chacun de nous attend de voir le
candidat coulé par une petite phrase en
15 secondes
nos reporters on se retrouve donc
ensemble à regarder la télé il n'y a
plus aucun contact physique seulement
des écrans la télé mais aussi twitter ou
le chat pendant le débat avec le monde
politique
heureusement après le débat est encore
la spin mme le service après vente du
candidat ceux des petits panneaux les
noms des principaux conseillers
comme d'habitude la campagne encore eu
raison de notre déjeuner ou de notre
dîner alors on s'accroche au directeur
de campagne de romenay romney c'est ce
favori mal aimé des primaires qui ne
parvient pas à décoller on n'a pas de
problème on est très confiants sur le
résultat de cette secousse la manière
dont les choses se déroulent pour le
gouverneur omni
on ne va pas gagner toutes les primaires
je vais vous faire une prédiction rien
que pour vous on va en perdre certaines
vous allez perdre l'iowa
on perdra certaines primaire je ne peux
prédire lesquels mais c'est une longue
course il y a beaucoup d'états qui
votent
on ne les gagnera pas tous le plus gros
problème quel est il
hop
sexies adversaires il a raison le
stratège de romenay en ce mois de
décembre les républicains se déchirent
new king reach et sa femme bien blonde
qui me fascine calysto
on va bouger maintenant mais je suis
ravi de vous avoir rencontré mme young
ingrid l'ultra conservateur qui menace
tous les autres un jour sur deux dans
les sondages il ya aussi michele
bachmann un petit tour et puis s'en va
avec ses sourires sa poigne ses
interviews elle sort par la petite porte
de la course
elle espère toujours un ministère et
puis il ya ce favori mal-aimé mitt
romney cet homme d'affaires en campagne
présidentielle depuis quatre ans qui
n'accorde de longues interviews qu'à la
chaîne conservatrice fox news
mais on a toujours droit à un petit
signe sympa pendant six mois
romney a fait toutes les émissions de la
chaîne favorite des républicains en
famille dans les studios de fox news
il présente toujours sa femme anne à ses
amis journalistes
[Musique]
lorsque le couple passe devant nous
c'est toujours la même chose c'est dire
autre chose que ces mots romney gelé
suivi un peu pour savoir
[Musique]
dans tous les états mitt romney aura
fait chaque jour cinq à six meetings
tout y est installée pour imposer un
homme presque déjà président dans ses
usines les spin doctors ont aussi
conseillé à mitt romney de porter un
jean
l'ancien homme d'affaires n'emportait
pas souvent pendant des mois
romney nous apparaît rigide peu à l'aise
dans ses baskets
quelle est la chose la plus importante
pour vous sur ces élections les emplois
il ya tant de gens au chômage qui ont
besoin d aide
tout ce qu'on peut faire pour créer des
emplois pour remettre les gens au
travail
c'est très important et c'est le message
que je veux entendre des candidats ce
qu'ils peuvent faire pour lutter contre
le chômage et remettre l'économie sur le
bon chemin
si romney un meilleur plan qu'obama là
dessus je voterai pour lui si obama mais
reprogramme je voterai pour obama pour
ces indécis la campagne romney a
minutieusement préparé chaque meeting
son entrée avec une musique très forte
puis le côté humain avec son épouse anne
malade atteint d'une sclérose en plaques
est toujours à ses côtés pour le
défendre et l'humaniser now qui
américain
après l'émotion de la bonne épouse
il y a toujours une petite blague adapté
à la scène du moment
la troisième étape le discours de
ramener martèlent les mêmes thèmes
pendant 30 à 45 minutes
les stratèges de romenay veulent aussi
qu'il termine ses meetings par des
attaques dur contre obama
à la fin de chaque meeting ramener sert
beaucoup de mains des lecteurs et de
supporters mais n'improvise jamais avec
les journalistes
par peur d'une gaffe
[Musique]
il ya des verts
ils vont
avec
pendant toute l'année romney talonne
obama dans les sondages
la campagne du président a compris qu'il
y avait un problème
il a fallu sortir et montrer à
l'amérique les citoyens pro-obama pas
dans les bruits des meetings mais
toujours dans les petites villes en
plein milieu de l'après midi comme ici
dans le new hampshire à manchester
derrière des fenêtres fermées aux
regards je ne suis pas un homme
politique mais je veux vous dire voici
de vrais gens et non des pions comme
dans les slogans publicitaires
ces mots sont à destination de la presse
locale et d'un état qui va voter
prononcée par un ouvrier licencié par
romney un brave homme déniché par la
campagne obama qui sait si bien tout
organiser un chômeur récupéré par les
élus locaux qui raconte à tous les
journalistes présents tout le mal qu'ils
pensent de romenay
mitt romney a tout inventé sa campagne
ces slogans mis sur son bus en fait il
n'a jamais travaillé dans une usine
il n'a jamais dirigé une usine ni était
un cadre supérieur
il n'a même jamais été le patron d'une
usine ou même d'une société qui
produisait réellement quelque chose
il a seulement été le président d'une
entreprise qui faisaient de l'argent
entre 1992 et 2000 pour 100 millions de
dollars
il a laissé toutes les compagnies faire
faillite l'opération a mis tout le monde
au chômage et ça a été un cauchemar pour
des tonnes de la campagne obama ne paye
pas cet homme mais finance tous ses
trajets dans le pays il est cajolé par
des jeunes de 20 ans venue spécialement
de chicago pour l'aider et bree fait
aussi les journalistes locaux
[Musique]
loin de washington chicago la ville où
obama installé son siège de campagne
nous avons eu cette année un accès
exclusif à la war room le qg là où tout
se décide
quatre fois nous sommes venus dans ces
lieux avec un deal à respecter
autorisation de filmer mais interdiction
de poser la moindre question
les cameramans sommes toujours escortée
par deux ravissantes jeunes blondes
ce quartier général d'obama est le lieu
où toute la stratégie c'est décidé il
est conçu comme une salle de rédaction
d'un site internet
moyenne d'âge 25 ans chacun des 500
salariés est relié à la base de données
du parti démocrate
une start up de l'élection 2012
il y à un service consacré uniquement à
l'analyse des logos des débats
république et pour chaque état un
département spécialisé sous le panneau
iowa je retrouve le bon copain de barack
obama revienne de 2008 à 2011
chaque samedi il jouait au golf ensemble
[Musique]
ce
opération voix est une spécialité pour
recenser les abstentionnistes toutes les
listes électorales de chaque côté de
ils sont étudiés de près sarah palin
avec un sigle sahara en affaires a aussi
son coin particulier
l'un des directeurs de ce quartier
général s'appelle ben labolt en cas de
victoire d'obama ce sera sans doute un
de ses porte parole à 31 ans
ben est considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs stratèges politiques actuelles
pour chaque demande de journalistes le
clan obama ne répond jamais par
téléphone seulement par e-mail
le seul qui utilisent encore cet
appareil est involontaire retraités
[Musique]
le
le président candidat ne fera pas
beaucoup campagne sur le terrain avant
l'été un déplacement par semaine
toujours proche du coeur de l'amérique
je l'accompagnent en virginie où pendant
deux jours ils sillonnent les villages
pour parler du chômage par téléphone est
conseillé de chicago multiplie les
conférences sur le financement de sa
campagne loin des dollars obama lui
retrouve le peuple noir et comme
toujours le meeting politique débute par
le serment de fidélité au pays
et
[Musique]
ensuite protéger comme il se doit
le président apparaît sur scène
très haut niveau
[Applaudissements]
depuis des années j'ai toujours remarqué
après cet éclatant sourire la même chose
de la foule
la joie mais aussi souvent la
stupéfaction de le voir en vrai et puis
il ya l'émotion et les réactions
épidermiques à ce qu'il ait dit ça c est
la raison c'est qu'il a raison
[Applaudissements]
vas-y
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
ne manquez pas
et
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup de formes obama il est le
président du peuple
[Musique]
battre au col où nous avons besoin d
aide
continues à te battre on a besoin d'
on a besoin de travail de soutien et
surtout que les partis au congrès se
mettre d'accord
on en a assez est ce qu'ils se
préoccupent de nous où est-ce qu'ils ne
pensent qu'à leur petit jeu égoïste
c'est ce que je veux savoir
ah ah
emporia les habitants dans l'un des
contes et les plus pauvres du pays
on a vraiment besoin de travail on en a
vraiment besoin
au delà des bonnes paroles et des
meetings obama ne peut rien faire pour
eux depuis 2010 son congrès divisé entre
démocrates et républicains rejettent
systématiquement tous ses projets de loi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'allée ton prénom je m'appelle molly
pourquoi es tu pour mitt romney
parce que je pense qu'il peut être élu
nous sommes ici avec ses terres un petit
village du new hampshire
romney doit gagner les primaires de cet
état
[Applaudissements]
les deux
bon
m
avec ses millions de dollars mitt romney
a non seulement dans son service d'ordre
ce jeune bien aimé mais aussi un soutien
parmi la police locale pour interpeller
au plus vite tout opposant ce jour là au
milieu des manifestants j'ai vu aussi
sur scène
le poids de la haine anti obama
nous ne pouvons plus supporter l'homme
le plus pessimiste que j'ai jamais vue
dans le bureau ovale barack obama ah
ouais c'est vrai les narcissiques
situait à peine achevée
si vous n'étiez pas aveugler par ce que
vous a inoculé obama vous comprendriez
que le travail reviendra en amérique
lorsque rome ni sera président des états
unis
prenez exemple sur un homme qui a
construit une ville dont l'amérique peut
être fier et non pas sur un politicard
de chicago
et j'espère que le président on regarde
bien sa télé car j'ai un message pour
vous monsieur le président c'est le
genre de comportement anarchiste l'écho
les risques que votre cynisme votre
envie de diviser a créé dans ce pays
rassemblés nous monsieur le président
ces scènes nous diviser
[Applaudissements]
si tu es notre homme
mitt romney est sûr d'avoir avec
christian coulisses un populiste qui
fait bien le sale boulot face aux
attaques
barack obama lui travail ils essayent en
vain de faire passer ses lois sur la
réduction de la dette avec des
républicains au congrès de plus en plus
hostile et cynique
[Musique]
entre de combat législatif épuisant
barack obama se distrait avec les people
george clooney et son combat inlassable
pour la crise humanitaire au soudan
vient souvent à la maison blanche
le tout hollywood se fait également
décoré un après midi de mars la presse
accréditée se détend avec le président
en pleine crise du budget pour assister
à la remise d'une décoration c'est
toujours pareil
la east room se remplit de vedettes un
peu intimidé il y a aussi une femme
bourgeoise de washington qui ressemble à
sharon stone net et ce jour là le
parrain était là
[Applaudissements]
barack obama a bien compris qu un
président démocrate ne peut repasser que
s'il est soutenu par hollywood et son
argent
ce jour là le par al pacino a donc été
décorés
[Musique]
depuis quatre ans je suis parfois
invités à observer en journaliste les
belles soirées du président des dîners
d'état comme en avril lorsque barack
obama a reçu le premier ministre
britannique david cameron
l'occasion de retrouver les puissants
qui peuvent en donner à ces dîners on
voit souvent anna wintour la très
influente new yorkaise directrice du
magazine vogue et d'autres qui côtoie ce
monde de la maison blanche médias
acteurs politiques clooney brunson john
legend
interdiction à nos reporters de les
approcher pour leur parler
alors on regarde et on décrypte ce petit
jeu de la connivence entre people et
pouvoir
[Musique]
chacun de ses deux candidats va dépenser
un milliard de dollars j'ai bien dit un
milliard on a maintenant ici ces
donateurs les plus riches est prêt à
dépenser pour leurs candidats des
millions de dollars ces gens-là désire
payer 10 millions de dollars pour un
dîner à la maison blanche doit trouver
un moyen de réduire l'impact de l'argent
dans la vie politique
avant l'argent n'était qu'un moyen parmi
d'autres
aujourd'hui il a tout envahi ça n'a pas
toujours été comme ça lâche
oui
fin de l'été l'ouragan sur tampa en
floride perturbe en août la convention
républicaine où le parti doit consacrer
micro mena comme nominé c'est un
intervalle régulier que toute la journée
de lundi
l'ouragan est bien et est arrivé sur
temps pas la ville où a lieu la
convention républicaine alors derrière
moi se troue un seul but montrer qu
obama n'a rien fait pour les américains
frappés par la crise américaine pour la
première fois attend pas et dans une
convention de ce parti le chiffre de la
dette nationale américaine change à
chaque seconde et est affiché dans la
salle les républicains mettent en avant
les valeurs cardinales de la société
famille religion patrie tout commence
avec l'hymne américain et un ténor
d'opéra
[Musique]
toi
bonjour je travaille pour la télévision
française bon jeu il vous êtes heureux
d'être là
je suis très heureux d'être là pourquoi
parce que nous sommes là pour élire le
président romney notre prochain
président et m dos roma ma pourquoi
romney meilleur que le président obama
ça devait sauter aux yeux de tous même à
vous les français
barack obama est le pire président de
toute l'histoire américaine
de quelle manière il a dépensé trop
d'argent
si vous regarder derrière moi vous voyez
la dette de presque 16 mille milliards
de dollars
c'était 5 milliards quand il est arrivé
au pouvoir et qu'est-ce qu'on a eu pour
ses dix mille milliards dépensés par le
président obama
j'ai bien regardé ivoiriens vous re
voteriez pour quelqu'un qui a gâché plus
de dix mille milliards d'argent public
non vous ne feriez pas
[Applaudissements]
attends pas le noyau dur du parti se
gargarise aussi de chants patriotiques
orchestré devant la presse une messe
100% conservatrice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ap
ouais
oui
[Musique]
ce qui va me surprendre c'est cette
grande nouveauté dans la communication
politique
regardez voici le couple vedette 2012
monsieur et madame au pain au ski david
sachant que mythe avait fait l'école de
droit de harvard lui a demandé de venir
à son chevet pour l'aider à écrire son
testament il avait des choses qu'il
chérissait et qu'il voulait léguer à ses
meilleurs lorsque mythe d'aller lui
rendre visite à l'hôpital
il avait avec lui un bloc-notes jaune et
un stylo ensemble ils ont fait le
testament de david une tâche qu'un
enfant ne devrait jamais faire mais cela
beaucoup apaisée d'agir après sa mort
nous avons donné son skateboard sa fusée
miniatures et ses affaires de pêche en
son meilleur ami il a aussi très
clairement exprimé son souhait que son
frère père et de sa petite carabine 22
long rifle
combien d'hommes aussi occupé
connaissez-vous qui prendrait le temps
de se rendre au chevet d'un enfant
mourant de 14 ans et de l'aider à
rédiger son testament
ce n'est pas tout mythe a aussi aidé
david a organisé son enterrement
mon fils voulait être enterré avec son
uniforme de boy scouts et voulait que
woods fasse un discours mythe a honoré
sa demande en lui sera toujours
reconnaissant de son amour et de son
dévouement
des parents qui confesse que le candidat
en est les a aidés lors de la mort de
leur petit garçon
le parti républicain ne recule devant
rien et le public achète
ça me touche au coeur
mais il nous vend vraiment très
émouvante et dur à entendre
[Musique]
et ouais ce bouleversant et c'était
parfait parce que ça montre qu'ils
romney est vraiment injuste un
politicien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à ce moment-là mitt romney n'est
toujours pas en tête des sondages en
campagne depuis six ans il a dépensé
plus de 100 millions de dollars pour
sillonner le pays avant d'arriver à
cette convention
le célèbre dan rather en est à sa 28e
convention celui qui a révélé au monde
les tortures d'abou ghraïb en irak se
veut à plus de 80 ans toujours critique
et incisif sur les candidats au poste
suprême
les joueurs aiment match omni n'est pas
un homme politique au départ il affirmé
mais faire campagne mais c'est faux
c'est la même chose d'ailleurs pour
obama c'est une étrange campagne et ces
deux là ne sont pas de vrais politiciens
comme bill clinton ou ronald reagan qui
adorait faire campagne
le point faible de romeny c'est son
manque d'authenticité avoir refusé la
publication de ses déclarations d'impôts
des années passées comme c'est la
tradition ici la fragiliser et beaucoup
se demandent s'il ne cache pas là
quelque chose mais sa victoire ne va
dépendre que d'une chose de la façon
dont les électeurs le voit évoluer au
sein de la droite
les élections américaines se joue
souvent au centre avec ces indécis qui
jusqu'à la dernière minute ne savent pas
pour qui voter alors romney qui dans le
passé a été plutôt un républicain modéré
doigts pour gagner la présidence tout
comme pour les primaires se pencher
davantage vers la droite mais si on sent
qu'il va trop à droite
il perdra si en revanche il arrive à
convaincre qu'il est plus au centre
qu'obama obama se retrouve poussé sur sa
gauche et c'est romney qui gagnera
pour convaincre
rome n'a misé sur la grandeur des états
unis nous croyons dans l'amérique
affiche sa campagne
lorsqu'il arrive pour prononcer son
discours ses communicants ont comme
d'habitude tout orchestré
l'objectif sera de le montrer moins
rigide l'humaniser et faire en sorte que
son discours diffusé en direct dans tout
le pays marque les esprits
obama
[Applaudissements]
non
mais bon
m
dans la salle j senti à ce moment là que
mitt romney avait changé ils se
battaient de toute son âme pour arriver
à la maison blanche entre nous
journalistes sous les ballons on s'est
tous dit que son discours très bien
écrits avaient aussi été très bien dit
l'équipe républicaine avait marqué des
points dans l'amérique profonde
[Musique]
et puis comme toujours lors d'une
convention aux états unis il y a eu
image finale
en france on n'a pas encore droit à cela
la famille sur celle autour du candidat
à cette convention de temps pas avec ses
cinq enfants et dix sept petits enfants
le parti a bien montré la famille
parfaite 2003
[Applaudissements]
à sa sortie de scène en coulisses romney
est resté en revanche comme d'habitude
toujours inaccessible par peur d'une
gaffe à nos micros
à wattignies
cela aurait pu marcher cette convention
elle aurait pu être un succès romney
propulsé en tête des sondages mais voilà
il ya eu un gros bug clint eastwood qui
du haut de ses 82 printemps a
complètement dérapé
personne n'a vraiment compris ce qu'il a
dit il est apparu sénile
j'en ai je te plains ce monsieur le
président comment fais tu joues avec
tout vos promesses de campagne de
réélection
que dites vous aux gens qui se demandent
que dites vous aux gens comment les gens
se demandent je sais qu'il ya même au
sein de votre parti des gens déçus que
vous n'ayez pas fermer guantanamo
c'était la soirée de maîtrise la soirée
devant des millions d'américains
on pouvait enfin révélé qu'il était
quand ce genre d'occasion se présente on
doit s'assurer que personne ne viendra
vous voler la vedette
pourtant ils ont fait venir clint
eastwood qui a fait ce truc complètement
bizarre c'est finalement ce que tout le
monde a retenu de la soirée les sondages
ont indiqué que les gens ont été plus
marqués par les propos de clint eastwood
que par ceux de mitt romney
c'est une bonne leçon à retenir nalité
jamais quel point dans une soirée
si vous ne savez pas ce qu'il va dire
[Musique]
c'était bien pour obama ce moment là le
moment eastwood
barack obama était attendu par son parti
pour y être intronisé en arrivant je
suis tout de suite frappé par cette
image
l'énergie la foule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui des milliers de démocrates venus
fêter leur candidat et comme toujours
sans complexe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant trois jours le parti avait aussi
décidé de célébrer les valeurs et
l'esprit de l'amérique démocrate avec en
prime time toutes les formes importante
du parti mise à l'honneur
oui ces femmes avaient quelque chose à
dire le premier soir
bonsoir je suis nancy pelosi
comme à guam j'ai mes petits enfants
m'appellent nini peau mais la politique
est une prolongation de mon rôle de mère
et de grand-mère pour les femmes
démocrates comme nous et notre travail
ne se limite pas aux prochaines
élections présidentielles mais à la
prochaine génération aux côtés du
président barack obama
nous sommes là pour relancer le rêve
américain
les idéaux l'idée que si vous travaillez
dur que si vous jouez le jeu
si vous prenez vos responsabilités vous
pourrez gravir une à une les marches du
succès à aix stm les femmes politiques
démocrates sont prêtes qui est unie
derrière barack obama pour que
l'amérique aille de l'avant
elle était forte ces femmes unis comme
pour la première fois le parti des
femmes
je vous le demande où sont les femmes où
sont les femmes
où sont elles vous êtes là
maintenant les femmes sont là
bon
les femmes des états unis y sont là
et nous sommes tout derrière le
président le président barack obama
calmez vous calmez vous il y en a qui me
parle sérieusement ce sont les femmes
démocrates
cette élection est importante parce que
nous ne devons pas revenir en arrière en
ce qui concerne les droits de la femme
en matière de sécurité sociale le droit
à l'avortement
il s'agit de nous les femmes de notre
corps c'est notre décision et pas celle
du gouvernement
j'ai des filles et des petites filles et
ce sont les droits des femmes qui sont
en première ligne dans ces élections
on y passe nous risquons une tout perdre
on était au pouvoir et nous voulons
continuer à avancer et surtout pas à
régresser voilà vous l'avez compris
c'est crucial le vote féminin pour
barack obama alors le lendemain michelle
obama la femme en chef pouvait arriver
avec orchestrée par les spin doctors ce
clip de rêve sur ses années de bonheur à
la maison blanche
[Musique]
plus que jamais dans l'élection
présidentielle américaine de 2012
il y a le chef d'état mais aussi son
épouse
associé jusqu'à la fin à son combat
[Applaudissements]
obama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du mec
cloclo diffusant dias que romney c'est
tout ça est ce qui nous écoutent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oui
mais pas mieux
oui ce dernier jouera la convention de
charlotte barack obama pouvait arriver
sur scène avec michel son arme fatale
[Applaudissements]
barack obama en 2012 reste toujours une
icône planétaire de la politique mais en
tant que femme j'ai vu ici à charlotte
quelque chose qui ne m'a pas plu et qui
m'a rappelé que tout ouïe reste
politique michel je t'aime et l'autre
jours le pays entier a vu à quel point
j'étais chanceux de t'avoir malia et
sasha mes deux petites filles
je suis si fier de vous tout ce que dit
barack obama depuis 2008 et scripts et
même ses déclarations d'amour à sa
famille alors la presse sérieuse n'est
plus dupe
[Applaudissements]
barack obama qui est quelqu'un de très
intelligent a comme on dit familièrement
perdu son mojo sa magie en 2008 il était
le candidat parfait il était en prise
avec le peuple
on est loin de cela aujourd'hui il est
en compétition contre microbes ni dans
une campagne très médiocre et il faut
bien l'admettre mitre nuit le talonne on
sent une certaine lassitude dans le
corps obama parle bien mais le chômage
et l'économie sont les deux thèmes
majeurs pour les américains
[Applaudissements]
on pardonne souvent beaucoup à obama
surtout lorsqu'on le voit ainsi avec son
éclatant sourire
mais en cette fin d'été à charlotte en
le regardant j'ai senti que quelque
chose n'allait pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sous les confettis obama semblait
distant loin faisant bien son job de
candidats mais trop vite malgré les
sondages
la photo de famille on s'est tous dit
nous presse accréditée que cette
élection allait très serré et la
catastrophe est arrivée
[Musique]
le premier débat télévisé à danvers
obama devant le monde entier avait un
autre visage
[Musique]
un homme refusant de se plier au jeu des
petites phrases un chef d'état candidat
fatigue et nonchalant et nous la presse
avide de chic et choc en a retenu que
cela change avec le temps les roses ce
fan vous savez même six mois lors de la
première campagne
il ne m'a pas enthousiasmé mais bon si
on regarde les choses de manière
objective
son bilan est extrêmement solide en
revanche et c'est paradoxal je ne crois
pas qu'il soit un très grand orateur il
a tendance à évoquer tous les sujets sur
le même ton et avec la même cadence
quelle que soit l'intensité du sujet
qu'il parle de ses filles ou de la libye
c'est pareil il semble à chaque fois
extrêmement bien préparé quand vous êtes
très intelligent que vous avez de
l'expérience à ce poste alors vous
pouvez compter sur votre charme votre
apparence et votre esprit
[Musique]
le
si vous vous imaginez que d'anvers dans
le colorado sebo peut-être mais comme
d'habitude je n'ai rien vu le
journaliste politique vit de plus en
plus dans des zones transformés en
parkings pour camions satellites
début octobre on était plus de 3000 à
répéter en boucle la même chose sans
jamais approché les candidats à d'anvers
je n'en revenais pas de ses moyens
démesurés amplifié par les chaînes
d'info continue les réseaux sociaux le
progrès technologique
cette élection pourrait se résumer ainsi
de plus en plus de médias pour une info
politique sur contrôler
[Musique]
et ce jour là dans les coulisses de
cette politique spectacle michael un
journaliste d'un média qui n'a plus
d'argent pour couvrir une élection
présidentielle américaine et qui
travaille ainsi
le french tv
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites ici nous
sommes dans les entrailles de la machine
nous sommes de kansas city dans l'état
du missouri
on travaille pour le groupe hearst basé
à washington mais nous on vient de
kansas city
voici notre espace de travail et
derrière on a un camion satellite
tout compte fait on n'est pas si mal
lotis on est abrité du soleil et on a vu
surtout les échafaudages tout autour
comme vous le voyez c'est vraiment luxe
le luxe au total généralement les
américains ont l'habitude de rester
digne en toutes circonstances on ne se
plaint pas
j'aurais aimé passer des heures avec lui
pour qu'il partage son expérience de
vieux briscard de la politique et du
terrain
[Musique]
en le regardant j'ai eu le sentiment de
voir une époque du journalisme en train
de mourir la communication en politique
se fait de plus en plus ainsi adam vers
nous à créditer privilégiées nous étions
dans la plus grande salle de télé au
monde de cette année électorale
mon souvenir préféré restera une image
non pas barack obama et mitt romney
mais cette femme gabrielle gifford sept
députés d'arizona sur laquelle un homme
a tiré dans un meeting en janvier 2011
très grièvement blessée elle a passé
plus d'un an à l'hôpital et est apparue
sur la scène de la convention démocrate
son retour symbolise qu'on ne peut tout
simplement pas à battre la démocratie
elle sera peut être candidate en 2016
non on parle déjà d'hillary clinton ou
du retour du frère de bush clinton
contraint bouche ça ne s'arrête jamais
et hilary présidente
yes je vous sens déjà intéressé faites
attention
la politique c'est une drogue dure qu'on
soit acteur ou spectateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]